انت اسماعيل كنت في جامعه الاقصى في
الساعه الماضيه ووافينا بالاخبار من هناك
ولكن في طريقك من جامعه الاقصى الى مستشفى
ناصر ما هي ابرز المشاهدات لما
يجري المشاهدات يعني ماساويه جدا ل نزوح
المواطنين وحركه المواطنين وتنقل
المواطنين يتنقلون على الاقدام وهم في
حيره من امرهم اين يتجهون اين يذهبون في
ظل هذا القصف الذي يستهدفهم في كل مكان
هناك حاله نزوح كانت من شمال قطاع غزه
باتجاه مدينه غزه وايضا بعض المواطنين
الذين نزحوا من مدينه غزه باتجاه خان يونس
الان ينزحون باتجاه مناطق في رفح هناك
حالات نزوح عديده وشديده ومتكرره لعائلات
مخصصه خاصه من اهال شمال قطاع غزه وكذلك
مدينه غزه وهم لا يشعرون بحاله من الامن
والاستقرار في ظل هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي
المستمر راينا المواطنون يقومون بعم بفك
فكه خيامهم في المناطق التي لجوا اليها
سواء في المدارس او حتى في المستشفيات او
حتى في الجامعات او حتى في المناطق
المساحات الزراعيه الفارغه التي استطاعوا
ان يقيموا وينشئ فيها خيامهم لكن في ظل
هذه الخطوره اطلاق النار والقصف المدفعي
المستمر لجا المواطنون الى فك فكه هذه
الخيام والبحث عن مناطق امنه واماكن امنه
في سواء في غرب خان يونس اقصى الغرب من
خان يونس وهي ايضا ليست منطقه يعني امنه
في ظل ايضا حاليا يتم هناك قصف من قبل
زوارق الاحتلال تلك السواحل بين الحين
والخر وايضا هذا يعني بان المواطنون لا
يجدون اي مكان امن في محافظه خوس مما
يضطرهم الى التوجه الى منطقه رفح و يعني
عديد المواطنين خاصه في ظل الظروف الصعبه
عدم امتلاكهم لوسائل النقل وكذلك عدم توفر
المال ل لدى هؤلاء المواطنين وسبل العيش
الكريم ايضا في مناطق التي تجون اليها
بعضهم يبقى على حالي في منطقه خانيونس
باعتبار بان في اي مكان يتجه الىي حد
يتعرض لعمليات قصف تقوم بها طارت الاحتلال
او حتى مدفعيه الاحتلال طيب اسماعيل هل
شاهدتم اي اليات عسكريه على الارض في
اثناء تحرك ام ان الامر يقتصر على القصف
كما ذكرت مدفعي وجوي وكذلك عبر الزوارق
نعم شاهدنا اليات الاحتلال في المنطقه من
غرب معسكر خان يونس والى اقصى الغرب من
المعسكر هناك احد المطقه العسكريه وايضا
في هناك باتجاه الغرب هناك جامعه الاقصى
ما بين جمعه الاقصى ومعسكر خار يونس راينا
حركه اليات اسرائيليه تقطع الشارع ال من
الشرق الى الغرب هذا الشارع يؤدي الى احد
المواقع العسكريه وقطعت هذه الاليات فعلا
هذا الشارع واتجهت باتجاه الجنوب من اسف
من باتجاه الشمال من ناحيه الجنوب هذه
الاليات قامت باطلاق النار هناك تغطيه
ناريه من قبل طائرات مسيره قامت باطلاق
النار بتجاه المواطنين الذين كانوا يمكثون
على البوابه الخارجيه لجامعه الاقصا تم
اطلاق النار عليهم من قبل اليات الاحتلال
وكذلك من قبل الطارات المسيره وهناك عديد
الاصابات قبل قليل كان هناك اصابه لاحدى
النساء بشظايا قذيفه مدفعيه اطلقت باتجاه
هذه البوابه التي تحدثنا عنها هي بوابه
شماليه لجامعه الاقصى
ومقابل هذا الشارع هناك
اليات من الناحيه الشرقيه ما يعني ان سلوك
هذا الشارع او قطع هذا الشارع هناك خطوره
كل لمن يتحرك في هذا الشارع لذلك يلجا
المواطنون بالتحرك باتجاه البوابه
الجنوبيه لجامعه الاقصى بعد قليل ساقوم
بمحاوله الوصول الى انترنت حتى يعني صضنا
بعض المشاهدات وكذلك تحرك الاليات في تلك
المنطقه وسنقوم ان شاء الله بارسالها بعد
قليل لقناه الجزيره ل تستنى وضع المشاهد
في حاله الحدث الذي وقع فيه خانيونس خلال
هذه الليله وكذلك صبح هذا اليوم فقط
للتاكيد مره اخرى اسماعيل الطريق الذي تت
واجد فيه اليات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يمنع
منعا بات من تواجد المواطنين فيه بل يتم
استهدافهم ب اطلاقات ناريه وكذلك قصف من
قبل
مسيرات نعم القصف مدفعي وكذلك اطلاق نار
من قبل مسيرات واطلاق نار من اليات
الاحتلال الت تمركز في غرب معسكر خان يونس
والذي يفصل هذا الشارع ايضا يفصل ما بين
المعسكر وكذلك جامعه الاقصى يبعد تبعد
الال عن جامعه الاقصى يعني عشرات الامتار
فقط متواجده هناك الاليات وتقوم بعمليات
اطلاق النار وكذلك القصف المدفعي هذه
الاليات اضافه الى اطلاق النار من قبل
مسيرات الاحتلال حدثنا اسماعيل عن اهميه
هذا الطريق غرب معسكر خانيونس وامتدادا
حتى جامعه الاقصى وطبيعه المنطقه
هذه هذا الشارع هو احد الشوارع الرئيسيه
والمؤدى المناطق الغربيه لمحافظه خانيونس
يمتد من وسط المحافظه في خانيونس حتى ح
اقصى الغرب ويؤدي الى شارع الى البحر
تحديدا ش بحر خانيونس هذا الشارع حيوي
ودائما في النقطه القريبه من معسكر
خانيونس في هناك منطقه منطقه الظهره
يتواجد فيها مواطنون بشكل كبير خاصه مع
تجمع المدارس الذي ياوي او تاوي هذه
النازحين عدد كبير من النازحين عشرات
الالاف من النازحين داخل هذه المدارس
وكذلك المستشفى القريب من منطقه ومن ثم
تبدا الحدود منطقه قط المعسكر مع نهايه
هذا هذا هذا هذه الحدود
تبدا منطقه فارغه تقريبا من المساكن ثم
تصل الى جامعه الاقصى في غرب محافظه خنيس
معسكر وكذلك جامعه الاقصى لا يتعدى الامر
سوى كيلومتر تقريبا وهذا هذا الكيلو تنشط
فيه اليات الاحتلال وتتحرك باتجاه من
المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه من المحافظه
اجاه المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه لمحافظه
خانيونس ما يعني ان قطع هذا الشارع وهو
الشارع الحيوي يمنع سيمنع حك المواطنين
وتنقل المواطنين من اقصى الشرق اتجاه
الغرب او حتى من الغرب اتجاه الشرق خاصه
نتحدث بان من الناحيه الشرقيه لهذا الشارع
يتواجد مستشفى ناصر وهو يخدم الالاف من
المواطنين وكذلك النازحين ويخدم ايضا في
ظل ال الصعبه وعمليه القصف ال الجرح الذين
يصلون الى المستشفى ويقدمون الخدمات
الطبيه اللازمه لهؤلاء الجرحى لكن قطع هذا
الشارع سيمنع وصول الجرحى الى هذا
المستشفى الا على سلوك طرق بعيده من
الناحيه الشماليه الغربيه للمحافظه وهي
مناطق اكثر امنا لدخول سياره الاسعاف وهذ
الطريق مؤدي الى مستشفى ناصر عبر منطقه
الصناعه التي يتواجد فيها ايضا نون ومن ثم
الدخول الى معسكر خانيونس والتوجه الى
مستشفى ناصر اذا قط قطع هذا الطريق
التاكيد هو قطع
لوصول المواطنين الى المناطق الغربيه
وتحرك المواطنين ايضا وايضا يؤثر على نقل
اصابات خاصه في ظل حديث عن اصابات عديده
في المناطق الغربيه لمحافظه خرونس